okay um welcome everyone to be silence
quantum Tuesday's seminar I hope you're
all doing well thanks for joining
so let me just remind you for questions
so I think when you join your muted
actually you're not but so when you join
your muted but you can unmute yourselves
and an ask a question so Renault asks
that you please interrupt him and ask
questions if for some reason it's easier
for you to type the question in the chat
you can also do that um and I see it and
I will drop the speaker but really you
should feel free to just speak directly
all right okay so today we're very happy
to have Ronald the world from silver uiq
soft and University of Amsterdam um and
when Ali is going to tell us about work
that he started working on with Sweeney
vos on who I think at the time with his
was his student that student at WI and
then he attended our quantum cluster two
summers ago gave a talk about it and I
think Andrew was there in the talk maybe
Robin was also there other people got
interested and they continued work and
so Ronald is going to tell us about
their their achievements on the on the
quantum component collector problem so
renowed welcome thanks a lot welcome
everyone and go ahead okay thanks
tomorrow yes so this is joint work with
Srinivasan Arunachala McDonald bellows
and your child's Robin Qatari and on
Cicero Spanish and indeed part of this
work was done in this wonderful summer
of 2018 that at the time is instituted
the previous Contin program so this is
about a coupon collector and coupon
collecting of course it happens in
theory it also happens in practice so
every year the Dutch supermarket chain
Albert Heijn this is kind of the the
Safeway of the Netherlands the biggest
one of the biggest supermarket change
they hand out these carts of soccer
players I guess in the US they would
handle hand out baseball cards but in
the rest of the world people care more
about soccer and if you spend too
50 at the supermarket you get one of
these cards uniformly at random and
there are 18 teams in the Dutch soccer
league 11 players per team so that will
be 198 different cards actually I'm
making making up these numbers here
because probably they will have more
than just eleven eleven cards per team
since there's also like people sitting
on the bench etc but let's say 198
different cards and let's say your
nephew really cares about getting a
complete set so they want to have at
least one copy of each of these 198
different cards so how much money would
you need to spend at over time in order
to get each card now clearly you would
need to spend at least 250 for each of
these cards right because every 250 that
you spends will only give you one card
so you need to spend at least the number
of cards 198 times 2 and out of euros is
495 euros um but the situation is
unfortunately much much worse because if
you have already almost all of the
players let's say you're just missing
one great player everybody else you
already have a copy of their card and
you go to the Albert Heijn to spend
another 250 let's say you're buying so
toilet paper to sustain you through a
lockdown what are the chances that is
one random randomly chosen card that
they will give you is actually the one
that you didn't have yet it's a very low
probability all right so you go to the
Albert Heijn you spend 250 and you get a
card you already have and you're very
unhappy you go again to the overtime
defying you look down spend another 250
get another card you probably already
have that one as well
so why is this this happening it's
because initially you're making a lot of
progress in this coupon collector
problem because you haven't seen any
energy cards yet at the beginning so the
first card that you get they're
definitely new the second card that you
get is probably different from the first
one the third one that you get is
probably different from the first two
when you're making rapid progress but
then they're the ends you're making very
slow progress and there's a very nice
mathematical analysis in expectation of
how many of these coupons you need to
draw uniformly at random because before
you've seen every coupon at least once I
think this is really an exercise in
the first few lectures you see in a
probability theory course it's very
clean let me show it to you so suppose
that you will have already seen I out of
the K possible cubot so K would be 198
here the total number of coupons you'd
like to get one copy of each coupon and
let's say you have already buy different
coupons right so there's K minus I
coupons left or K minus are soccer cards
left that you would like to get and
you're given one of the K cards
uniformly at random so the probability
that your next coop only is a new one
one that you haven't already seen a copy
of this is K minus I divided by K right
super elementary probability theory and
that means that if you look at the
expected number of samples you need
before you see your first new coupon
it's the reciprocal of this probability
right so if you have probability P of
having a success then the expected
number of tries before your success is 1
over P so if you already have seen I are
the K possible coupons you need roughly
an expected number of K divided by K
minus I new samples before you you get
your new in the first time you get a
coupon that you didn't already have for
a soccer cart that you didn't already
have and you can you can head up these
expectations because so when I is 0 the
expected number of trials is just 1 when
I is 1 the expected number of trials is
K divided by K minus 1 etc so you can
just add this up over the total number
of coupons you would like to get
eventually and so this becomes the sum
of i running from from 0 up to k minus 1
of this expected number of samples
needed to get here next Google and this
is a very simple sum so you can
rearrange it a little bit you pull out
the K out of the sum you you rename K
minus I to J and now you just have K
times a harmonic series a harmonic
series of course is essentially the
natural logarithm of K so the expected
number of samples you can determine it
quite precisely it's K times natural
logarithm of K plus an order K term so
that's a lower order term and this is
substantially bigger than K
so for instance if K is 198 as in my
soccer cards example that's eleven
hundred and sixty-two sevens so instead
of just spending 250 for each new court
you actually especially at the end of
the process have to spend massive
amounts of money to finally see all the
coupons and the reason is you're making
very slow progress at the end right and
1162 samples times two and a half euros
per sample that's that's almost three
thousand euros that's much more
expensive than then if you could just
sort of choose which car to buy for your
250 and I'm sure the supermarket chain
is aware of this this is of course it
tricks to get you to spend more and more
and more um and you're unlikely to
finish earlier see there are unlikely to
finish earlier because you can calculate
the the variance in this this X in this
number of samples and it's it's on the
order of K squared which means that the
the number of samples you will actually
have to do right previously we just
calculated an expectation but the number
of samples you actually have to do
before you've seen everything at least
once is k1 K plus an order K term so
you're very unlikely to be lucky and to
to to use a number of samples that's
much smaller than K long K and this is a
quantum talk so of course my question is
can quantum somehow help in this process
and of course if you're just given
random samples there is no quantum there
there's really nothing much you can do
so there the answer would be no but
let's broaden the scope a little bit so
suppose that instead of uniformly
running samples over the K soccer cards
or the K coupons you're going to get
quantum samples and a quantum sample
would be sort of the coherent analogue
of a random sample so that's just a
uniform superposition over the set s so
let's say that we have a universe of
size N and there's case there's a set of
size K in that universe and you'd like
to collect every number in that set s so
there's still K coupons and somehow they
live in the universe of size N and your
sample your coherent sample would now be
a uniform superposition over all the
elements of s right so cat s will be 1
over root
and then just to sum over the basis
states overall the eyes that are in the
set s so you're given such a States
you're probably given multiple copies of
such a state just like in the classical
case you would be given multiple random
samples and then your goal is to kind of
do a quantum measurements and and try to
extract the set as quickly as you can
meaning using as few copies of the state
cat s as possible
now one thing you could do with the
state of course is just to measure it
it's a stupid thing to do but you could
do it what happens if you measure it
well you just get back to the classical
situation of uniformly random samples
from s right and we know by the analysis
of the previous slides that's the number
of samples needed is essentially kalon k
plus a lower order term but of course we
know that if you want to get your
quantum magic to perform you need to do
something clever before measuring so the
question I'm going to ask here is is
there is something something smarter
that we could do that would use fewer
than K log K copies of the state s in
order to recover the set s and let me
give you the short answer so it's a
yes/no answer so the answer is yes if if
the the size of the set is kind of close
to the universe in a universe size so
I'm going to use the letter M for the
number of missing items meaning the
number of elements of the universe that
are not in the set s so that's n minus K
and it will turn out that you can get an
improvement for quantum coupon collector
meaning you can get by with far fewer
than K log K copies of ket s if this
number of missing items is small and if
the number of missing items is big the
answer is going to be no so that's what
I'll spend most of this talk on
explaining the positive and a negative I
will start with the maybe I should pause
a second here too to let you read this
and like
if there's any questions just just
interrupting or you can type in the chat
and and tamaki and relay it to me okay
no questions at this point so let me
first explain the positive part so if if
we're trying to reconstruct a sense of
size K and K is very close to the
universe size and then it will turn out
that you can beat this classical coupon
collector so that's what I'll explain
now and the trick here is that you can
learn to set s by learning its
complement right so the universe - a set
s and if there's few missing elements
then the universe - is set as it's a
small set and what we're going to do is
we're going to show how you can take a
number of copies of the state cat s and
convert it into essentially a uniform
superposition over the complement of s
from which you can then sample by just a
measurement and recovering the small
complement of s is much more efficient
than recovering s itself just because
there are a few elements in this
complement so how does it work well
we're given the state cat s in fact a
bunch of copies of them and the trick is
to observe that the state can s can be
written as a linear combination over the
whole superposition I hope you can see
my mouse so by this cat's brace n I just
mean a uniform superposition over all
the N elements in the universe so your
state cat as a linear combination of
this uniform superposition over the
whole universe well some states can say
which is orthogonal to this uniform
superposition and you can see the
weights here so the weights of the
uniform superposition over all universe
is the amplitude is root K over N that's
pretty close to 1 because case pretty
close to them and then there's this root
M over N which is the amplitude for the
state kept sigh and it's kind of sigh it
has this form this is just a sort of a
dumb calculation that you can do if you
define your state can say like this then
s is this linear combination of the
whole uniform superposition over
everything and the state sorry and the
states why is interesting why because it
has a lot of weights K over N is almost
1 it has a lot of weight over the
uniform superb is
of s complement so essentially the
states I is negative the uniform
superposition over s complement assuming
in deeds that said that M is much much
smaller than n equivalently that that K
is kind of close to N so let's try to
take a bunch of copies of KS and try to
convert these into one copy of chai from
which we can then sample and this will
probably give us elements of the
complement of s so what do we do we take
one copy of this cat s sort of a
coherent quantum version of the random
sample over the coupons and we measure
it with the two outcome projective
measurements where the first operator is
just a projection on the uniform
superposition over the whole universe
and the second projector is just
everything else so the n minus 1
dimensional complimentary space you can
calculate the probabilities of the two
possible outcomes and because the
amplitudes of cat's eye in this
decomposition is root M over N if we do
this measurement on one copy of cat s
then with probability M over N that's
kind of small but ok but with
probability M over N we obtain one copy
of sy and we know when we succeed it
right because this projective
measurement is going to tell us whether
the outcome was the first or the second
possibility and if it's the second
possibility we're happy because we
obtained a copy of this tape side but we
only succeed there with small
probability M over N but you can just
repeat this right so you can just repeat
this using n over m copies of s or cat s
or rather an expected numbers and over
any copies of cat s you you do this
measurement on on all of these copies
and with high probability one of those
is going to succeed and give you a copy
of size M Phi is essentially a uniform
superposition over the complimented s up
to small error which I'm going to ignore
in this talk right and if you can make a
uniform superposition over the
complement of s you can just sample from
that you can sample from the complement
of s you can do it a number of times and
now you're back in the situation of the
classical coupon collector but on a much
much smaller set namely s complement
instead of s itself Metin s compliments
has just M elements which means that
just by classical coupon collector
roughly M log n sorry M log M copies of
this state which is uniform over s
complement suffice to recover the whole
set s congruent and if you have s
complement you also know as itself which
is the goal here and now we need it
roughly n over m copies of the starting
state cat s to produce one copy of Kent
s complement so in total we're going to
use something like n Times log M many
copies of cat s for a quantum coupon
collector and notice that what we're
doing here is very simple we're not
doing some fancy some fancy non product
measurement on the tensor product of all
of these these copies of s we're just
doing state-by-state measurements right
we just do a very simple measurement on
each copy of s a few of those succeeds
and we just measure in a computational
basis the resulting states for the few
measurements that succeeded and this is
going to give us as component and the
point here of course that if M is very
small let's say M is constant then only
order n copies of cat s suffice for a
quantum coupon collector in contrast to
the n log n right so this is the
situation of the positive result I
mentioned before if the number of
missing elements is small so if n minus
K is small then you can be then using
coherent quantum quantum samples you can
beat the classical cuckoo collector by
by a log factor and this is yeah so
there's two ways to look at this you can
either think of these as I'm sort of
kind of a cute a measurement quantum
measurement problem but of course if
you'd like to attract the attention of
venture capitalists you would call this
quantum machine learning right because
you're just actually learning something
here you're learning this service and
you can do that quite efficiently and
but I want so let me just pause again
for questions because after this I want
to show that this is upper bound on the
number of copies is actually tight so
any questions now would be a good time
to ask them I'll take some tea in the
meantime as state why is it square root
K over m times disks and so it should be
like K or something why would it be key
you can just calculate this this is the
uniform superposition over everything
this one over root any freedom to get
ket n is normalized and I mean this is
just a calculation you can just verify
that this equation holds it's not super
insightful but the good thing is that it
allows you to somehow extract the copy
of s compliments from a bunch of copies
of Cadets okay so so this is this
quantum coupon collector it can at least
this upper bound says that you can beat
the classical coupon collector by a log
factor if M is very small on the other
hand if M is polynomial in n then this
quantity here is just the same n log n
that you would also have in a classical
case so in that case you this at least
is set up this algorithm this
measurement scheme it doesn't beat the
classical coupon collector and what I
want to show in the next few slides is
that this this upper bound is actually
tight so this is the negative part of
the talk you can only hope to beat the
quantum cook the classical coupon
collector using quantum coherence if M
is very small right so I'm now going to
go to the lower bound parts lower bounds
on the number of copies of ket as you
need to recover they stay this this is
set s so matching lower bounds I mean
matching up to constant factors we have
to claim this is what I already said so
let's assume the number of missing
missing elements is at most half right
previously we saw the interesting cases
where m is very small so let's assume M
is no bigger than half of the universe
so the size with the set K you're trying
to recover is at least half of the size
of the universe so I claim that you need
essentially K log M many copies of the
state s in order to learn this the set s
itself
I think this matches the upper bounds
protocol of the previous slide so how do
you prove something like this so our
approach is to use the so called
adversary lower bound and this might be
slightly mystifying because the
adversary lower bounds is a lower bound
in quantum query complexity and there's
no queries here right the only thing
that that's happening here is we're
given a bunch of copies of the state cat
s so for every s there's like a state
which is a t4 tensor product and we just
want to distinguish those states and you
might think we thought so as well you
might think that a better approach here
is to use just a very good measurement
and what is a very good measurement well
of course we have no idea what the
optimal measurement would be for this
system here where you're given T copies
of cat s anyone awareness but there is
this thing called the pretty good
measurements which is also known as the
square root measurement and it's known
that this measurement which you can just
write down you can write down its POV M
elements these measurements it is known
to have a success probability that's
already quadratically worse than the
very best possible environment right so
if the very best possible measurements
which maybe you don't know has success
probability 90% then there's pretty good
measurements which you do know has
success probability at leasts point 9
squared which is point 81 percent so if
you don't really care about the constant
factors that should be good enough to
analyze the behavior of the so called
pretty good measurements in
distinguishing the different possible
states where by States I mean defaults
tensor product of the state cat has for
all the different possible sizes so we
tried this first and it leads to very
complicated formulas that we expended a
lot of effort on and we couldn't really
analyze it so instead I'm going to use
this adversary lower bounds which is a
query complexity lower bounds and I'm
going to use it without any queries and
why owner
this is possible well it's because this
is a very lower bounce rate assist this
is due to in its original form - tor -
and then it was extended by oleh Pollock
and then worked on further by like
people like Rijkaard it has been
generalized to also give a very good
tool of analysis for states
transformation problems anyway in a way
what we're trying to solve here is a
state transformation problem where we're
starting with a state that's T T fault
tensor product of the state cat s now if
some I want to transform this to just
the classical description of s right
let's change say just a 0 1 vector with
support on the elements of s so this is
a state transformation problem and this
is actually something that the adversary
lower bounds can characterize and the
way to apply the the adversary lower
bound is to set up a bunch of matrices
and look at various norms of these
matrices so that's what I'll do now so
let's first consider the gram matrix of
the different states that we want to
distinguish right so for every case set
s there's going to be a state like this
and you can have a matrix M indexed by a
different sets s so that's in n choose K
by n choose K matrix and as the entries
of this matrix so let's say the rows are
indexed by elements s and the columns
are indexed by elements S Prime at the s
comma s Prime entry of this matrix M you
just put the inner product of the states
with s at the state with s Prime and
because these are T faults and their
products these are inner products or
just teeth powers of the inner products
between s and s Prime right and notice
that the inner product between s and s
prime catalyst and Canada's Prime really
only depends on the intersection size of
s and s Prime
so this is this property is going to be
imported soon so this is the the gram
matrix M which sort of characterizes the
overlaps between the different states
that you're trying to distinguish in
this problem now let's define another
problem here sorry another matrix of the
same dimension to n choose K by n choose
K and this is a very simple matrix it's
just sort of the photo negative of the
identity matrix so it is zeros on the
deck
and it has once off-diagonal alright so
you can stink of this as the old ones
matrix minus the identity so that matrix
I call F and you can immediately get
from this from sort of general machinery
that's known about the adversary lower
bounds that's the state transformation
problem that we are trying to solve it
can be solved with high success
probability if enough if and only if the
so-called gamma 2 norm of the atom our
products the entry wise product of these
two matrices is small right so you have
the matrix M is grow matrix it's in n
choose K by n choose K matrix if the
matrix F which is zeros and ones for the
same dimension you can take the hardware
product of these two matrices this will
really just zero out that I can all of
em because F is everywhere one except on
the diagonal and then you look at the
so-called gamma 2 norm of this of this
resulting matrix and you should think of
this gamma 2 norm sort of as the minimal
error probability of any measurement
scheme so the state transformation
problem can be solved meaning there is a
good measurement to distinguish all
these states if and only if this gamma 2
norm is small let's say point 1 or
something like that and I don't want to
define the gamma 2 norm itself but
rather look at its dual because the dual
norm because that's it's easier to
manipulate for us so you you can
alternatively define the so this is the
dual formulation of the gamma 2 norm of
the matrix M circle F so this is the
maximal operator norm you can get if you
maximize overall so-called adversary
matrices these are distances just any
matrix of the same dimension so you
maximize over matrices gamma whose
operator norm is at most 1 you look at
the Audemars product of gamma with the
matrix m and m circle F and you maximize
its operator norm and this looks kind of
complicated but you can show that if
this quantity is small so if the gamma 2
norm of M circle F is small then you can
actually solve the then you can solve
the
and you cancel the the state
transformation problem with high success
probability with low error probability
but the good thing about this dual
formulation is you can also use it for a
lower bound right so so let's say that
we fix our T we want to prove our lower
bound so let's say that we fix our T the
number of copies to be too slow then
there shouldn't be a good measurement
scheme there shouldn't be a good state
transformation scheme so the comma to
nan should be big and this is something
you can prove by just exhibiting one
preserving matrix right if I can find
one particular matrix gamma that makes
this operator norm of gamma Circle M
circle as big let's say I have then that
shows that if I use these T copies of my
state cat s no matter what I do my state
distinguishing protocol will always have
a large error probability so this is how
we're going to use a lower bounds we're
going to exhibit a specific adversary
matrix to show that gamma circle m
circle F has large operator norm and how
do you approach something like this well
you need to use symmetries so how do you
construct such a gamma the thing to
observe is that the matrices m and F
that we care about here they have a very
nice symmetry namely that's the s comma
s prime entry of both of these matrices
just depends on the intersection size of
the set s and s prime right so for M
looking here this should be kind of
obvious because if you look at E the
inner product between the state cat s
and the state cat s prime this really
only depends on the number of elements
that are common to the s and s Prime
so clearly the entries of the gram
matrix M are only dependent on the
intersection size of s and s Prime and
the same should obviously be true for
this matrix F because here the only
things that are that are 0 or the
elements on the diagonal where s equals
s prime and all the other elements of F
are 1 so the matrix pattern circle F
that we want to analyze it has this nice
symmetry and in order to to find a good
so to construct a good adversary matrix
to to witness that this norm here
big we need a kind of math a
mathematical tool box that respects this
symmetry and the mathematical toolbox to
use is the so called Johnson Association
scheme and this comes back in in all
sorts of branches of mathematics
sometimes under the name of those
messner algebra it also has to do with
the Johnson graph that is used in
quantum work algorithms so what is the
Johnson Association scheme it's
essentially just a set of matrices which
can be characterized in different ways
so let's define first define boolean
matrices a 0 up to am of the same
dimension as before so and choose K so
these matrices have the same dimension
as the M and the F that we care about
and and let's say that these matrices we
define them to be indicators of a
specific intersection size between s and
s prime so AJ is going to be a boolean
matrix and I'm going to set the s comma
s prime entry of this matrix equal to 1
if and only if the intersection size of
s and s prime is equal to K minus J and
so this way I'm defining these these
different sort of intersection
intersection witnessing matrices 0 of 2
am a very simple matrices they're all 0
1 matrices and they don't overlap so if
you take let's say a I circle product
out of our product with a J very
different from J you're just going to
get 0 because if a is a 1 in a certain
position it means that's SNS Prime and
that that position has certain
intersection and it means that AJ will
have a 0 there because SNS prime cannot
have two different intersection sizes at
the same time so and then you can look
at sort of the linear span of these
matrices so everything you can get by
linear combinations of a 0 2 a.m. and
this forms an algebra and a different
way to to characterize the same algebra
or rather to have a different different
basis for the same algebra is there also
exists pairwise orthogonal projection
matrices project
of the same dimension again that easy
Rowell to e em and they spend the same
space and that means that every AI
matrix can also be expressed as a linear
combination of the projectors ej and the
coefficients in this linear combination
those are called the eigenvalues of the
Johnson Association scheme and
conversely you can also Express the ejs
as a linear combination of the AJ's just
by inverting this linear transformation
here so every 8th EJ you can write it as
1 over capital n that's the dimension of
the matrices times the sum over the AIS
with coefficients QJ I and these numbers
here they're called a dual I can tell
you of the Johnston scheme and most
importantly you can also express the
atom are products of VI with AJ as a
linear combination of Els and the way to
see this as as close I already mentioned
before that if you look at the circle
product of AI with AJ then this is going
to be the zero matrix
unless I is equal to J and if I is equal
to J you just get back
AI itself because 1 times 1 is 1 so that
means it's clear that the the circled
products of the a matrices can be
expressed as a matrices but then by
these linear transformations it should
also be possible to express the circle
products of Eli with EJ as a linear
combination of K is and also of Els
and the coefficients in that's linear
transformation in that's that linear
combination that are called the
so-called crime parameters of the
Johnson scheme and so for every pair e
IE j on the left hand side you have the
the entry wise product of the matrices
inej on the right hand side you have sub
linear combination just of the matrices
al and the linear the coefficients here
those are called the trial parameters of
this johnson scheme you can actually
derive them with a bit of effort from
the eigenvalues and the duo eigenvalues
but you don't have to because these
parameters are all known then you can
look them up in fancy yellow books Jerry
I didn't get why are they not just
products
so E is expressed as a linear
combination of AIS and you said the AIS
are basically orthonormal with respect
to the hardware product so the a ice or
pairwise orthogonal to each other in sex
they are like if you multiply them to
entry wise together you get 0 or you get
the order so if I compute the hardware
product of e I and EJ simplify it'll be
very simple I'll only get I mean suppose
you wants to sort of derive these crime
parameters from the the eigenvalues and
the dual eigenvalues what would you do
you would look on look on the left hand
side here the is circle product ej we
have an expression for e I and EJ in
terms of the AIS yeah you plug that in
here you get this big linear combination
where with a sum over I and J of all the
circle products of AIS with a J's and
then it needs things simplify yeah but
you still have kind of fancy
coefficients in front there
so these Craig parameters they're not so
easy okay okay
a different thing is that we didn't have
to figure them out you can just look
these things up in books um okay now how
does this relate to to what we're trying
to do let me remind you of what we're
trying to do right so we have this
matrix M given by the the inner products
between the states we care to
distinguish you have this matrix F which
is just a photo negative of the identity
matrix and we want to show that's M
circle product F has large gamma 2 norm
and we want to do that by exhibiting a
particular matrix gamma whose operator
norm should be at most one such that
gamma circle product M circle product F
has large operator norm and by large
think at least 1/2 so that's what we're
trying to do right so like I said the
entries of the matrix M they only depend
on intersection sizes and that means you
should be able to express them as a
linear combination of these AI matrices
because the AI matrices they're just 0 1
matrices that sort of indicate whether
SNS Prime
certain intersection or not and this is
easy to do so you can easily express
them as a linear combination of the AI
matrices at the AIS themselves are
linear combinations of the EJ matrices
so you can also express em as a linear
combination of the EJ matrices and what
is our adversary matrix going to be it's
also going to be a linear combination of
the EJ matrices so I'm going to pick
parameters gamma J I'll say what they
are in the moment such as gamma here
this gamma matrix the adversary matrix
that we want to construct in order to
witness the large gamma to norm of M
circle F I'm defining gamma like this
it's a linear combination of the each
ace with parameters gamma J and I'm
going to choose the current J's likes it
like this so government 0 up to gamma M
minus 1 so everything except for the
last one they're all equal to 1 and
gamma M I'm going to choose to be some
number between minus 1 and 0 so
everything is 1 except for the last
coefficient which is a little bit below
0 and this has some good features so one
thing to observe here is that remember
these ejs they're Paris orthogonal
projectors and that means that the
largest eigen value of gamma the
operator norm of gamma that's just the
largest coefficient gamma J right if you
have different projectors it's like you
have sort of a block diagonal matrix
each block multiplied with gamma J and
the max the maximum gamma J that's going
to be the operator norm of gamma and
remember a necessary matrix gamma one
property it needs to have his operator
norm at lost Warner but I'm choosing all
these gamma parameters to be equal to
one or at most one in absolute value so
it's follows that that our gamma matrix
defined in this way has operated normal
most one that's a good thing another
important property of this construction
and this is this is out a choice of
gamma and it's determined so the gamma M
is the only parameter which is not equal
to one it's in fact a little bit below
zero this is determined in such a way to
ensure that the diagonal entries of
gamma are all equal to zero
so I won't explain how this works but
you should think of Epsilon mm sorry II
am the lost lost projector in this
linear combination as being sort of by
far bigger than everything else and that
means that by by choosing gamma mm you
can kind of steer the trace of the
matrix gamma and it turns out that that
all the entries on the diagonals gamma
are equal so if you can make it trace
equal to zero then actually the diagonal
entries of gamma will be equal to zero
so I'm skipping a bit of detail here but
I'm choosing this parameter to little
gamma m to ensure that all the diagonal
entries of gamma are 0 why does this
matter it matters because if I now take
the entry wise product of gamma with F
remember F is the matrix that has zeros
on the diagonal and once elsewhere then
this leaves gamma invariance right it is
gamma already had zeros on its diagonal
I can multiply entry wise I can multiply
it with F but it doesn't change anything
so gamma circle product F is equal to
gamma and this is good you can let me
remind you what we're trying to do we're
trying to show that this matrix here
gamma circle M circle F has large
operator norm now by my choice of gamma
and because the circle product is
commutative this M that this F sort of
drops out you can put it here you can
entry wise multiply it with gamma it
just disappears so we only the only
thing less to care about is lower
bounding the operator norm of gamma
circle hmmm I know so okay so why do
these crime parameters come in the
reason is gamma is a linear combination
of the ej matrices M is also a linear
combination of the ej matrices so if you
take a circle product of gamma with M
you get a linear combination of circle
products e I with EJ which using the
crime parameters you can trains
translate back to a linear combination
of just the ELS
and then you can just read off the the
largest eigenvalue of the resulting
matrix as the largest coefficient in
this linear combination of Els
because every every matrix that's a
linear combination of the e L matrices
it's operator norm as just a largest
coefficient in that decomposition so all
that's left to do now and I'm not going
to sketch that it's a kind of a long
calculation which even involves
calculations similar to what you see in
classical coupon collector but the
bottom line of that calculation is that
if the number of copies T is much less
than K times log M then the large then
the effect the first coefficient if you
express gamma circle M in terms of the
ELS the first coefficient is already at
least 1/2 meaning that the operator norm
of gamma Circle M is at least a half and
this establishes the lower bound because
this operator norm being big means that
every possible measurement scheme that
tries to take T copies of cat s and
learn as from this must have a large
error so this this ends the lower bound
part that I wanted to talk about again a
good time to stop for questions
okay so now I want to maybe I should
have done this first but I want to so
this kind of concludes what I wanted to
say about the quantum coupon collector
right so the upper bound part shows that
using roughly K log M copies you can
recover s and the lower bound says that
this number of copies is tied up to
constant vector and now I want to give a
bit of a bit of motivation for why we
cared about this this kind of type
problem and the motivation comes from
Peck learning probably approximately
correct learning so let me just explain
how this this quantum coupon collector
and the fact that it's that it beats
classical Goodman collector how it is
says something interesting about Peck
learning so what is a Peck learner for a
concept class so so let's say you're
trying to learn a function a boolean
function on a domain of size N and you
have a class of possible functions right
so there's an unknown function coming
from this class and you're trying to
learn it and how are you trying to learn
it well you're given examples of this
function sort of points in its truth
table so an example and I'm talking
classically here an example is just a
pair X comma F X where X is distributed
according to some unknown distribution D
and you can think about this D is sort
of nature or some process that generates
your data so there's an unknown target
concept F and you're given examples
multiple examples that of this form
where X is distributed in every example
X is distributed according to the same
unknown distribution D so the is a
distribution on on this set here right
and your goal is to to to learn F and
that's usually too much to ask so your
goal is to learn as approximately and
even that is probably too much to ask so
you're asked to probably approximately
correctly learn F that's what what Beck
learning is all about so he goes to find
hypothesis H that's a matter function
hopefully close to F and close to F is
measured in the following ways so for
every possible target function that
you're trying to learn for every
possible data generating distribution D
the probability
if you were to draw another example
according to the distribution X the
probability that your hypothesis H
misclassifies that example compares to
what's the unknown target function f
does that probability should be small at
most Epsilon
so a good learner achieves its with high
probability let's say probability 2/3
right so just to repeat what a Peck
learner should do it should take a
number of examples of this form
hopefully not too many use those to
somehow produce hypothesis H which is
some other function and this H should
disagree with with the function f you're
trying to learn only with probability
epsilon where that probability again is
taken under the unknown data generating
distribution and this is kind of
important it's important in fact
learning that the examples are generated
by the same distribution that's
eventually used to kind of evaluate
whether you learnt well or not this is
like having it I would say if you have a
history teacher who really focuses on
World War 1 and justly fills its lessons
with lots of stuff from World War one
but then on your exam you get only
questions from World War two that's not
kind of not fair so it's important here
that's the the final sort of measure of
correctness of your hypothesis is
according to the same data distribution
D that generated the examples so that's
the the goal of back learning and
there's a message amount of theory about
this and there's one very fundamental
theorem about this which kind of
characterizes information theoretically
the number of examples you need to
achieve back learning and it says that's
the required number of examples is up to
a constant factor equal to the so called
VC dimension of the concept class C
you're trying to learn I won't explain
what that is but it's on cognate oriole
measure of complexity of the concept
class that you're trying to learn so a
class that's very big there's very many
complicated functions this will have a
bigger if you seen I mentioned in a very
simple concept class so the number of
examples you need is this VC dimension
divided by epsilon accuracy that you
want so if you essentially if you want
to learn with n to be T be fairly sure
that your overall error at the end is at
most one percent the number of examples
that you need skills like roughly a
hundred times the VC dimension and this
is really a cornerstone of computational
learning theory and the fundamental
theorem has the property that if you
want to achieve it so there is always a
learner which learns well using at most
as many examples but the learners
sometimes has the property that's the
the good hypothesis age that it outputs
is not itself an elements of the concept
Class C accessible so you should allow
so called improper learners here and you
can of course try to restrict the
learning algorithm further not only that
it should output a good hypothesis so
something that's close to F in this
sense but also that it should be
restricted to only outputting hypotheses
that are in the Class C from which your
target concept comes all right so let's
say that you're trying to learn neural
networks and the only thing you're
allowed to output is a neural network
not a decision tree that would be called
a proper learner and it's known in
classical computational learning that
the fundamental theorem fails if you
enforce your learner to be proper so
requiring a to be proper in some cases
can significantly increase the sample
complexity of the problem you just need
more examples if you want to have so
much data that you can actually actually
output a good hypothesis from the from
the concept class C and a simple example
is actually based on coupon collector so
there is a concept class C or explain in
a minute what it is we're a proper
learner needs vc-dimension C over
epsilon times another log factor look
one over epsilon many examples
all right so asymptotically this is this
is more than what's the fundamental
theorem says so requiring learners to be
proper can increase information
theoretically how much data you need to
learn and here's an example so let's
consider the coupon collector problem in
this very simple case where you have a
universe of size n and the set s are
trying to learn as size n minus 1 K is n
minus 1 so there's really only one
missing element so there's the set of s
that you want to learn it's complement
as complement as far as one so
effectively you're just trying to learn
one missing element and you can look at
the the
set of functions that are indicators of
such sets and this is a very simple
concept class if you look at the truth
tables of such functions it's just a
column of ones with a good zero in one
position so this is a simple concept
class in effect it's VC dimension is
just 1 but let's say that we want to
learn this concept cross with a very
small error absolute sets to 1 over N
and let's say you consider distributions
that are uniform on the support of FS
and then classical coupon collector
implies that for this class here you
actually need n log n symbols right and
that's that's asymptotically bigger than
PC dimension over epsilon because VC
dimension over epsilon is only n in this
case so forcing the learner to be proper
meaning that it you have to output a
function of this form or equivalently
after I would have said as the right set
s with one missing element this actually
sort of boosts increases the number the
required amount of data by a log factor
and makes it a synthetically bigger than
what the fundamental theorem says an
interesting thing is that this is
separation so this is this is one of the
few examples that we know that separates
proper and non proper across the Quebec
learning this example fills in a quantum
case where you're given coherent
examples instead of random examples and
that's just in disguise the the upper
bound that I mentioned before if you're
trying to learn a set s with one missing
elements from from uniform
superpositions over that set order n
copies of this set suffice instead of
analog in and this leads out for an
interesting question I mean this is
really just a starting point but it's
really just this leads over the
interesting question maybe it's possible
that in the quantum case proper and
improper learning are the same in terms
of sample complexity but there's a
question that I don't know if you want
ok so the question says what is the age
for this example in the improper case I
think they're asking what's the age that
the improper learner is so that the
distribution she would consider here
would be the one setter
okay so I guess I mean so every FS in
this in this set it's truth table it's a
column of once with one zero at one
special place and all of those functions
are very well approximated by the
constants one function so what the
improper learner would do is it which is
output the constant one function and
under all the distributions we consider
this this has a small error compared to
the function you're trying to learn but
it's not in a class so the old ones
function is not in this class C so
there's kind of a trivial trivial
improper learner but if you want to do
proper learning learning you should
really identify the set s completely
because you're supposed to output an
elements from this from this this
concept class and you can show under
certain distributions that if you output
any other elements from the concept
class yes your error will be bigger than
epsilon which you're not allowed to do
so by setting epsilon so small we're
sort of forcing the proper learner to
really learn to set s and then then
you're just sort of thin you're in a
thinly disguised version of the
classical Google collective problem it's
just the number in the chat going up so
maybe there's more questions you want to
read to me no that says thanks that's
why it went home they go it's always
good thanks
yeah so I think this example even though
this is what what motivated us to study
this condom coupon collector I think
this is somewhat unsatisfactory because
it raises the interesting question
whether quantumly proper and improper
learning could be equivalent in terms of
sample complexity and we're not
answering that question at all still an
interesting open question the only thing
we're doing is we're sort of destroying
the one example we know classically that
separates proper and improper learning
okay so one last slide before the
summary so one of the things we actually
did assignments in summer 2018 is
generalize this model a little bit by
considering the case where you're not
only given copies of the state s get s
but you also have the ability to reflect
through the state s what I mean what I
mean me my dad's well
it's kind of not unreasonable because if
you can if you have a machine that can
give you copies of the state can s it
might well be that you actually have a
unitary which can convert an initial
state can 0 into PS and if you have such
a unitary and you can also you can do
you as well as you inverse that's good
enough to reflect through the state s so
by reflecting through the state s I mean
some unitary that maps cat s to get s
and anything orthogonal to get s to
minus itself so let's just assume that
instead and that in addition to having
copies of cat s you can also reflect
through the state cat s and this makes
you a lot stronger in terms of quantum
power because it means you could do
things like amplitude amplification to
kind of zoom in on the set s or quickly
right so the goal is still this learning
task there's an unknown set s of size at
K in a universe of size N and our
quantum algorithm should learn set s and
if you can reflect you can do that
faster than if you just have copies of
Kadesh so I want to show that now so
again just like in the case of our
optimal measurement scheme we're not
going to find the elements of s directly
but rather we're going to find the
elements of s : and the way we do that
is by amplitude amplification so we
start with a uniform superposition over
all the elements in the universe
that easy to construct and then using
amplitude amplification we can actually
rotate this to a uniform superposition
over the complements of s you can do
this using amplitude amplification and
the cost of this is something like
square root and for M this is very
standard so they won't explain the
details so it just generates uniform
superposition of the complement of s you
measure it you get your first elements
in the complement of s you know you want
to do this again
but instead of generating the state
which is the superposition over a
complement of s you want the complement
of s except this one element that you
already have so you're now rotating to
everything in a complement of s that you
haven't seen yet and this is going to
have amplitude amplification cost square
root of
and minus 1 divided by M minus 1 you
measure the state he gets a new element
in s AZ bar and the point is that I 1
and I 2 are different here they're
guaranteed to be different so you're
avoiding this annoying thing that you're
having coupon collector that at the end
you're very unlikely to see new elements
this we just avoids using a blow to the
amplification and you just keep doing
this until you've seen all the elements
of s complement and then you know both
AZ component and as itself now what is
the cost of this well you just sum up
the cost of these these amplitude
amplifications over all the steps right
cause by the way I mean the number of
reflections we use for the number of
applications of u and u dagger and this
turns out to be asymptotically square
root K times M and this is significantly
faster than if you just have copies of
cádiz available we also show that this
is tight we also get a balance for for
the other case so again I'm assuming
here that M is not too big at most half
the universe we have another bound which
is also tight for the other regime so
this brings me to my conclusion I think
this is sort of world x so summary
classical coupon collector what is it
there's a set of size K in the universe
of size N and you want to learn it from
uniform samples of rest how many do you
need pail ok quantum case you want to
learn again the same set s of size K
from a universal size N and now your
instead of given uniform samples you're
given coherent quantum examples so
uniform superpositions instead of
uniform samples or s and now it turns
out that the number of copies of the
sample that you need so the number of
coherent samples you need is roughly K
times log M which in particular means
that for small M you beat the classical
coupon collector there's something
substantially smarter you can do with
these quantum states KS than just
measuring them and it's smarter but it's
not super fancy because like I
emphasized when I when I described the
scheme there's there's nothing sort of
non product going on here you just get a
state s you do a simple measurement if
you succeed you measure the resulting
state in the computational basis you do
this state by state and the
just gives you said s eventually we also
have tide bounds for learning set as if
additionally you can do reflections
through the state and let me end with
this open problem here are the quantum
central complexities of proper and
improper back learning the same for all
concept classes I think this will be
quite an intriguing result we can't
prove that the only thing we did is we
we removed the example that disproves
this in the classical case yes so that
concludes my talk I can't hear you
tomorrow I said thank you Ronald and I
was a plastic okay
thanks everyone is doing but they're not
in using them so I can't anything except
for you yeah so I mean anyone questions
maybe what they think about it I had one
very very naive question I hurt myself
with this was very strange but I think
this is because should I meet myself no
no it's because I just wanted to ask you
a question under us you want to ask you
a question I can ask myself my question
after comment on Russia so I wanted to
ask this example that you that you
showed so there yeah in this improper
versus proper learning
you basically hopefully that there is
like a logarithmic overhead but but I
what if you choose like epsilon to be a
much smaller epsilon and still this to
be a function that you mentioned seems
like a good good good good candidates so
it seems that you have much bigger
separation in that case not absolutely I
don't know well I mean so so picking
epsilon much smaller it means it is
making n much bigger right so we're
choosing epsilon to be one over n here
and a sense
defines Absalom and therefore it defines
the size of the coupon collector problem
you need and then the number of examples
that you need skills like lock whatever
epsilon over epsilon which is the same
as n log n so it's it's not that not
that you can improve this to n log
squared n or something like that
so expressed in terms of n it's always n
log N
you
but why can't you should just choose
epsilon to be I don't know one third in
the venerable M if you choose epsilon to
be one third stand both in the classical
in the condom case order one example
suffice so you get an asymptotic
separation here in in terms of the
dependence on this epsilon so in the the
non proper case you have the dependence
which is linear in one over epsilon in
the proper learning case you have a
dependence at least for this example
that's that has an extra log 1 over
epsilon factor here so you only seen
asymptotic difference for small Epsilon
so the intuition here is that things
become difficult when you reach this
regime where basically there you only
need to find a few rare elements missing
from yours that or something like that
well that's one way to see that you need
classic penis you need something like n
log n examples it's really if you sort
of sort of cut through the notation it
really just is the coupon collector
problem and and the thing is that's
forcing the learner to misplace reverses
it's a really incompletely identify to
say this but what are you doing the case
like at least one third and then very
few I think in that case you would just
output the old ones function so notice
that all these functions in this concept
cause they're very close to the old ones
functions it is of course possible that
you're a distribution either good puts
any notice or available on the One X
where F s is not equal to one but this
you would see from a small number of
samples
so yeah I don't understand like wouldn't
be an improper learner
if you output the ovens function that
that's the whole issue that it's not
exactly so the difference between proper
and improper learning asymptotically
only shows up if you set your epsilon to
be very small
you
right so the fundamental theorem says
that an improper learner for an improper
learning dimension over Epsilon examples
suffices the lower Bart you get from
classical coupon collector is that for
this concept class
so remember VC dimension is just 1 for
this concept class but the number of
examples feelings for proper learner
learning is log 1 over epsilon over
Epsilon so it's it's bigger than what
you need for improper learning by a log
factor and this log factor only becomes
asymptotically significant for small
Epsilon
okay like well unless I just like no my
mind my question is that we say that if
I set up stone to say I don't want over
ten month or whatever then one
possibility is to output the ovens
function but I but I thought that the
old ones function is an ISA is not a
proper output regardless of the optic
disk is not sidonis that yeah so if they
want proper learning and then you need
look one over epsilon times one over
epsilon many examples we just switch on
the light here it's getting dark if we
should discuss this after to talk give
other people a chance or something
let see if there's other questions and
then I can also stop the recording and
you guys can continue trying should I
look at the chatter each other okay so
unrig is asking if there's a similar
theorem for properly renamed or as your
fundamental theorem it's a good question
so you can certainly do proper learning
with so if you replace the lock one over
epsilon by log n you can do proper
learning for every concept class and
this follows from so there's this nice
sort of there's a set of core lemma
called hours level Sowers level in
impact learning and Sowers lemma says
that if if your concept class is based
on don't confuse N and M here if you
stack if I stick the notation of this
slide then Sowers lemma says that the
the if you have a concept class of VC
dimension D then the number of
this upper bounds the number of possible
concepts in your concept class by
something like log n to the power D and
you could now just do proper learning as
follows you keep your your class C this
is the class of target functions and a
proper learner should find its
hypotheses in that class eventually and
it is simple and simple and simple and
every every new example that you get as
an absolute probability of eliminating
every function from C which is more than
epsilon away from the target
so every new example that you get it
kind of eliminates and I guess a 1 minus
epsilon fraction of C and now you just
keep going you keep getting new samples
you keep removing from C all the
functions that are inconsistent with the
examples that you've seen and the total
number of examples that you need now is
going to only depends on epsilon and the
size of the size of the concept class
and this is the size of the concept
class you can upper bound in terms of VC
dimension using the Sowers lemma so a
general upper bound for proper learning
is VC dimension times log of n in this
notation for n divided by epsilon and in
this example just happens to be the case
that not one of epsilon is the same as
log n ok little access Thanks ok let me
ask my question I think it's an easy
question so I was just wondering if you
are is just a calculation but I couldn't
do it in my head if if you asked for
what's the best way to encode all sets
of a certain size into a quantum state
that let's say you fix the number of
qubits to be log and hmm how many
samples would you need to recover to set
you're inside of the
forcing it to be this superposition just
a lot actually want to use some sort of
simple volatile bound lower bound whole
evil based lower bounds on the number of
copies is it which was asking for an
upper bound yeah if you use finger
printing well I don't know what's the
best way to do this just just uh just
some packing argument yeah
fingerprinting is not going to work in
this case of course because the
different states cat s and s prime they
can be extremely close if they differ in
just my starting point is the set s and
I want to encode set and good s into
some state s is that when I'm given many
copies of science I can recover
scientist doesn't need to be catalyzed
it could be something and choose K
possible sets right I see so you're just
asking like what is the dimension need
it if you have n choose K possible
vectors that are pairwise almost
orthogonal
to be I wanted to fix that I mentioned
and asked how many copies so in
dimension it's also not just almost
orthogonal I think because though it's
not that I want to distinguish pairs but
I want to recover s so what does
recovery mean in this case no recover s
so identify the state Oh is she in that
case the number of qubits should be
something like K times log n right
because you're getting that that many
bits of information by recovering the
service
right probably the lower bound the
information-theoretic lower bound is
trite but in that I was asking that's
worse than what you get from our Johnson
scheme the lower bounds
I think we're talking at cross-purposes
here well I wanted to fix the dimension
of each state to be longer so in in your
talk the dimension of each cat s is
sorry the number of qubits is log n and
the question is how many copies of it
hmm so I wanted to ask the same question
and also fixing the state to have log n
qubits mmm asking if there is a better
state than katas that allows you to
recover s C so in our case so you need
[Music]
let's consider the situation where
quantum coupon collector requires the
same number of samples as classical at
so so let's say that that K or let's say
that M the number of missing items is
polynomial in n yeah so then our lower
bound says that you need something like
n log n copies of the state and each
copy of the state is itself log n qubits
so the number of qubits you need to be
given is something like n Times log N
squared this of course is information
theoretically terrible because if I want
to encode 1 1 out of the the n choose K
possible sets K times log n it's just
classical bits would suffice and over -
it's not that far right well sole object
Airport with that information theoretic
lower bound allows me to encode States
into non product states I wanted to ask
of groups yeah so yeah one way to do it
would just be to kind of firm I mean to
just in enumerate the elements of
actually that's not efficient a better
way to do it is just a giftie the
incidence vector the characteristic
vector of the set s using n classical
bits this of course is not a product
state yeah it's not all the terms of
product of copies of the same state and
I'm not sure what you're getting at with
this question so maybe I could deal a
better answer if you tell me where
you're going with this
ok let me tell you I'll take it off take
any other questions take it offline and
then I can ask you more precisely so are
there there are other questions if
there's no other
let me thank Ronald on behalf of the
audience for his for his seminar
let me also announce that next week at
the same time we'll have a talk by you
once who from UMD and he's going to tell
us about his work with Andrew Charles
Myntra and Nathan we've been suchan Zoo
on a three of trotter error and that
seminar next week might be the lesson of
the program because the week after that
we will have a workshop we might have a
seminar okay so thanks everyone thanks
for knowledge and I wish everybody